hi guys I'm Alvin its Anka and today we
are gonna be showing you some crazy
through techniques we are gonna be
learning how to make 200 octopus balls
in 10 minutes
that is one ball every three seconds
that's a lot of balls not a lot of
minutes but first we gotta go learn from
the master so let's go it's very cold
let's get lunch what are you doing
is that how you get such big forearms
yeah you know forms oh my god that is
the size of my head so massaging it what
does that do to the octave tenderizes
tenderize makes it happy like who
doesn't like a massage I would be very
tender and relaxed after 45 minutes
that's right well this is takoyaki aqua
meaning octopus yaki means to grill what
components is takoyaki made out of three
things the octopus the batter in the
topics so we already went through the
octopus so I have to cook it in a way to
time it right with the batter as well
batter which is your dashi your soup
stock flour and eggs I have a drill have
a drill yeah so I have the soup stock
ready add my flour of a certain amount
of weight of flour inside the batter as
well a little bit of light soy sauce and
then once that's done we put in the
grill a little bit of scallion from
tempura bits and then I used something
called Shiro dashi so now that a
takoyaki is done how do we serve it some
takoyaki sauce I make my own sauce
Kewpie mayonnaise dry roasted seaweed
caught solution flakes I'm like not
talking very much because I want to keep
my saliva in my mouth cut the video
I'm gonna show you guys how it's done
you guys gonna do it - oh boy we are
wait can we count this counted it is an
18 18 18 18 18 18 nice Karl make some
balls
[Music]
Oh taco here we go
we are not oh you're not doing this you
have to be very good at multitasking
okay I'm so focused yeah this technique
dude you can go so bad with one hand
how long does it take to get this good
call eight years eight years this is the
gold standard for what we're gonna have
to try at the naked not gonna lie I'm
feeling really intimidated
I am super intimidated so no these are
done and they're ready to eat my mouth
it's creamy octopus is a nice chew it's
so comforting it's so good this is the
standard this is what a master of eight
years takes to make though now I'm done
you guys ready yours we are doing this
but practice run first because we're not
confident yet matter time there you go
just cooperate just like what she's
doing there yeah putting the taco in the
takoyaki alright next is Scotty Franklin
kinda over yeah soon thanks when you
make tempura is the leftover bits gonna
add little crunch more texture Wow
beautiful glass sure that is it fight
soy sauce and fish extract so now we let
it cook for a little bit it's starting
to bubble yes well how do you know what
to do what where I take the pic here and
just push it in push it in
much of the batter into the holes
already tuck it in into little nice
balls we're gonna cut the batter down
the middle okay
so just right here just go down for free
go down to the right turn wow man this
is like intense this is crazy so the
goal of this is to constantly turn
without burning it is fun though when
you scoop it and like the bottom very
sad right right again this is only 18
we're supposed to do we were gonna aim
for 200 because we know that's the bar
but but waiters we're gonna work our way
up there Wow look at that
what the heck around five o'clock okay
oh right there whoa hold me back hold me
back anyway this is death pretty much
yeah what do you think I might never let
me move it but you weren't expecting
what was that exactly one two look good
so now we practiced you ready to do this
I feel better to do this oh we have your
vote of confidence
[Music]
all right we're gonna attempt to do 54
which is a hundred and eight balls let's
do it let's get some balls cut the video
cut the video all right
oh god I'm spilling everywhere no a hole
left unfilled alright oh my god it is
hot up here so hot in here but we are
keeping on all of our clothes go let's
go let's go I feel like I'm like out of
takoyaki stand right now
oh sure dashi where's my other Pig
yo yo yo where's my pick yes please help
me thank you thank you thank you thank
you little one this one cutting time you
really have to go fast
my middle is really hot steam laundry
god it's so hard
gimme Oh yours looks so good what the
heck I'm like panicking y'all's like
playing overcooked but in real life oh
my god yes it is and I don't like that
game because it's really stressful go in
get in get in it's like tucking your
shirt in whoo I don't understand how you
do this Apollo this is crazy yeah Carl
whoo not bad element thank you you're so
good - yeah you have to give each ball
individual attention let's do this all
right one hand do a little 5 o'clock 5
o'clock whoa whoa whoa whoa 1 2 3 4 5 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6
bring the bottom one that was cool I'm
cool that was cool
we're doing great I really like how far
we've grown
in the past 20 but are we done
we did it how what do you think good
yeah good nice almond I'm pretty proud
of what we've done 108 balls let's plate
this up all right
they're my balls are really big Oh cut
the video paint us so oh yeah then try
to eat a big handful look alright Carl I
guess this is it
can we ask you to be the judge of our
dishes
the document that's a big one yo thank
you Thank You Carl
oh this is great you guys did a really
really good job yeah really really did
you thank you
this was 108 falls in plus or minus 10
minutes who knows what we'll be up to
next Alvin yeah if you guys have any
suggestions for foods that require crazy
skills or techniques send them our way
you want to check them out and we want
to give it a shot good bye peace out
[Music]
[Music]